people are talking about the regional
comprehensive economic partnership it
includes China Japan Vietnam and more it
is that a threat quote-unquote to the US
well I would have said it's mostly a
geopolitics threat rather than an
economic threat I mean it's not not
likely to be any kind of tight economic
integration these countries are just too
diverse and - you know distrustful each
other in fundamental ways but it does
mean that the extent that there's rules
setting you know we won't be at the
table in China will and to the extent
that there's a just a general sense of
who who are you looking at it but people
I had lots of conversations about TPP
and a question for for Obama
administration people is why are you
doing this the economic case is really
not all that compelling and they always
said geopolitics we have to be at the
center of this stuff and not gonna
happen but you know here's what
quick-quick focus here if the u.s. is
not in your trade deal what are you
gonna do as an exporting current account
surplus country you gotta sell to
somebody we're the biggest consumer in
the world isn't that leverage in deals
with China in leverage with in a deal
with the EU we're chat where Germany is
so trade dependent isn't that the reason
why people are gonna have to deal with
us and deal with Trump well they'll have
to deal with
nobody's gonna cut us off nobody's gonna
say oh we don't you know but what are we
gonna do are we actually going to go and
and I mean maybe under Trump maybe we'll
go you know start just breaking breaking
our commitments to say rip up the WTO
and start imposing tariffs but that's a
heck of a step and as my old teachers
used to tell me the danger is not
retaliation as emulation the whole
system falls apart if we do that so are
we willing to go down that route maybe
but if we're that crazy then I don't
think you know the the leverage is going
to matter one way or the other this is a
question on a lot of eco or eco team
here at Bloomberg News mind a question
from my fellow reporters Craig Torres
asking about NAFTA why has Mexico been
able to move up the value chain more
substantially why is it exporting low
labor costs why haven't they developed
intellectual properties doesn't show
this was simply a low cost wage
arbitrage for American companies we're
both American and Mexican workers really
didn't win I think that's the big rap
against a lot of these trade deals
multinationals wind their shareholders
win the workers didn't I think if you
want to make the case for Mexican
benefits you really want to look at you
need to look at Mexico regionally if you
only look at those five northern states
of Mexico it get a very very different
story one piece of Mexico actually has
converged significantly on the US so
it's not it's not zero now that's still
disappointing no question that people
who thought that Mexico was going to be
the next South Korea have been very very
disappointed and then we have to ask
well okay it turns out just being open
to international trade isn't enough and
the Mexico's problems of infrastructure
has problems of Education it has
problems of corruption development is
tricky some we you know no one really
knows how to do it and it's it NAFTA by
itself wasn't enough now for the US yeah
to some extent it's wage arbitrage but
you know that some of that is actually
helping us based enterprises compete
with third parties so I'm not gonna
claim that was a great thing for workers
on either side of the border but it's
certainly not the demonic thing that
some people portray it as I want to ask
you about the border adjustment tax in
the in the sense of in part its
supporters say it's very important in
Paul Ryan's budget plan because if you
want to cut taxes you have to pay for
that and one very low-cost way to do
that is with a border adjustment tax do
you agree well it's not really low cost
right now border adjustment taxes paid
you know import taxes paid by a US
consumers the same as as any other tax
it's the idea that it's somehow going to
full-on far and there's anything it's
just a different tax and you know there
are different kinds of border adjustment
tax there's the the kind that everybody
will help that has a bat has where it's
really just part of a sales tax then
there's this really you know the DB CFT
which is a real you know triple naproxen
concept it's very very serious
headache-inducing but there it's it's
much more complicated but again it's
it's not clear that it's any kind of
real revenue alternative is just a way
of shuffling around who bears the
corporate profits tax and the end since
the the end of any you know at the end
of these proposal is always going to be
that US corporations end up paying less
and that means that US consumers are
going to end up